h
lychen meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem video am
freitag und zwar ich weiß ich weiß es
tut mir leid
sonst kommen freitag immer die comments
allerdings habe ich mir gedacht da am
dienstag schon ein recht langer command
kam in einer recht langen folge falls
sie das nicht gesehen habt mache ich
euch hier irgendwo seine anmerkungen
dann wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr dann
darauf oder halt auch nicht jedenfalls
bin ich derzeit am vorproduzieren beim
eine klausuren vorbei sind und ich von
donnerstag bis sonntag in den urlaub
fahren sonne commands folge vor zu
produzieren beziehungsweise allgemein zu
produzieren dauert immer zwei bis drei
stunden im schnitt und alles mögliche
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
heute kommt man keine commands nächste
woche wieder ab den nächsten wochen
immer pünktlich allerdings habe ich mir
dann gedacht dass ich mal einfach
sondern euch sondern keine map
vorstellung zwar hat der user fahrenheit
das findet ihr natürlich alles in der
beschreibung verlinkt damit der
fahrenheit darauf ich werde angerufen
von escape sox was ist mit dir du bist
gott leid für meine aufnahme
ja süß der band nämlich heute beim durch
was gar nicht wo ich stehen geblieben
war also das ist vom user fahrenheit ihr
findet alles das in der beschreibung
verlinkt falls es selber mal zocken
wollt weil es egal dass uns war ihr habt
wahrscheinlich und titel gesehen es ist
candy crash in minecraft da oben sehen
wir noch diese diese komische kugel die
man hat wenn man fünf gleiche kriegt wir
lesen uns das erst mal durch sowie 90
plus und wollen 100 volume 100 räumlich
und vw habe ich 90 ist maps prototype
don't forget that if you don't know how
to play klicken ob dies ein singleplayer
resort pack 3 wie candy und was für
einen resource pack ich hab das noch mal
nachgeschaut angeblich ist das resort
pack mit drin
so sieht das ganze übrigens erst mal aus
wenn wir hier das haben das ist halt so
ach ja es ist mit drin sonst hätten wir
da ich diesen komischen iphone home
button also des resource peking muss
halt einfach euch die welt downloaden
und dann habt ihr das resort pack
automatisch mehr drin wir haben hier die
level wir fangen einfach mal mit level 1
und dann seht ihr schon haben wir jetzt
einfach kennen die crash in minecraft
und wenn wir das jetzt steuern möchten
können wir einfach hier drauf hüpfen
dann seht ihr schon davon abhängt dass
du an so komisch zu knistern und dann
kommt mir das beispielsweise hier
einschieben
hier entschieden
denn auch hier reinschieben jetzt haben
wir die sachen quasi miteinander
verbunden und erstmal alle die kanye
crash nicht kennen
falls es nicht kennt ich denke viele
werden es kennen aber man muss immer
drei oder mindestens drei von den
gleichen bonbons hier verbinden das
heißt denn hier könnte ich jetzt
beispielsweise einfach nach oben
das soll jetzt funktion jetzt den können
jetzt ganz einfach hier beispielsweise
drauf packen und dann sehe ich schon
dass das gericht dann könnte ich den
grünen hier einfach mal darauf springen
und den mit dem wlan n hier zwischen
dann habe ich die beiden gequetscht und
somit muss sich quasi das ganze so lange
machen bis irgendwie das level vorbei
ist ich habe keine ahnung wann das level
vorbei ist also beim richtigen technik
rasch auf dem handy ist es halt noch so
dass man immer so vorgaben hat
beispielsweise ja oh du musst so und
soviel züge soundsoviel wahl was
schaffen oder irgendwie so aber hier hat
man ihm gar keine vorgaben oder mach ich
mal hier noch mal eben so einen zug dann
mache ich hier noch mal eben was hier so
also das ist quasi so die steuerung man
muss halt hoch hüpfen und an wen ich
quasi dieses item hieraus sorgt dann
glitzert das wie ich euch verschwendet
dann glitzert das wie ich euch dann es
glitzer ist auch vollkommen egal gehabt
auf jeden fall vorhin schon gesehen dass
es funktioniert ich schaue ob sie jetzt
geht es ihm wieder sind die mal hier
getauscht wir können hier auch tochter
random swaps only you say no more posten
als box das heißt beispielsweise erzähle
ich könnte diesen blauen beispielsweise
da mit dem roten tausch war nötig da
noch einen allerdings wenn ich nichts
mehr tauschen könnte könnte ich einfach
hier draufklicken und dann seht ihr
schon es wird was so getauscht dass ein
paar sachen wieder funktionieren das
heißt ich könnte die ganze zeit drauf
klicken
ich habe den süßesten aller dinge guck
mal
jetzt kann ich mich alle gelben löschen
und das wäre dann quasi level 1 dann
kann ich ja beispielsweise bis level 15
gehen ich hoffe da noch hören nur 215
und hier habe ich jetzt beispielsweise
als vorgabe dass sich diese dinge hier
zerstören muss das heißt diese weißen
flächen wenn ich jetzt nämlich mal
beispielsweise ich hier oben den gelben
hier habe ich denen jetzt an gewählt da
gut wie ich das ding jetzt wieder
abwählen weiß ich nicht ich wollte
eigentlich den liedern in der rolle
runterzunehmen euch noch eine funktion
zu zeigen allerdings könnte ich auch
hier einfach mal was tauschen und zwar
ich möchte ihn abwählen
wenn ich jetzt mich beispielsweise mal
diesen hier nehme diesen schönen wie
lernen hier diesen schönen den schön
wenn ich den mal dafür darf ich dein
auto jetzt habe ich hier den
niederlanden angewählt und tauscht
beispielsweise
gelben und entweder schon dass da oben
dieses weiße feld wo zum etwas
freundlicheren und das gräuliche fällt
in das fröhliche fällt ihr sind einfach
weg und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
mal wieder diesen nie lernen hier mit
dem hier tauschte sich schon die ganze
reihe hat sich so ein bisschen entfernt
also hier wäre jetzt das ziel des spiels
einfach diese weißen flächen so mehr
oder weniger zu entfernen das war es
dann auch schon mit candy cross
eigentlich viel mehr ist hier eigentlich
gar nicht möglich also ich find's
einfach nur cool weil sowas in minecraft
ist einfach hammer dass man so was alles
damit machen kann ich weiß nicht ich
könnte ein ganzes buch darüber schreiben
was man alles machen kann und dass maria
auch zur zeit bei schreibe zurzeit ein
buch über minecraft von command & klar
und blut wenn ihr es noch nicht wissen
was passiert denn wenn ich mich jetzt
rein theoretisch mal umbringen würde was
wird dann passt ja das ist nice auf
jeden gamer aut 1 scheiße zu langsam
game auf ich bin gern als ok super ja
das war candy crash in minecraft es euch
gefallen natürlich meine bewertung
freundschaft auf jeden fall bald mal
bürger schaut hundertprozentig mal bei
fahrenheit vorbei
der ist in der beschreibung verlinkt wo
ist denn überhaupt jetzt hier das wo bin
ich denn hier seht ihr noch mal mit wie
das hier und da alles gemacht wurde
ja denn ihr blog auf mehr videos haben
und dann sehen wir uns bestimmt mal
irgendwann wieder und nächste woche
dienstag und freitag kommen wieder
commands und